good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy home day hope
everyone's having an amazing hump day
humping someone that they love and adore
in a consensual manner we are getting
over the hump you guys it's really
exciting this week is just chugging
along quite slowly yeah it's been tough
you know yeah it has been but
after this we will be
over the hump and then we'll just be
talking about sliding into
afl and we are officially like in the
holiday season like i know we have been
in the holiday season since november 1st
but like now in new york you can't walk
into any building they have like trees
and the sad little menorah it's nice no
it is nice it's it's cranked up all the
way and it's an exciting time i really
do always love this time of year like
work wise new york wise it's
it's
it's a peaceful time the most wonderful
time of the year as melania judice once
said it's the season
was that gia or melania i actually think
it was giant
melania does it hey stephanie
and melania likes to um dance and rap
and yeah like does girl bands dkt that's
what they were called right yeah um
before we start today's show i do have a
present for you
for me i did bring
well it's not from me it's from aunt sue
oh okay so this is the gift that i
transported back i believe this was in
detroit
aunt sue i don't know i wouldn't read
the letter outline i won't i would never
violate answers trust like that
oh my god what does it say it says born
to read oh that is so cute
i can't see
and by the way i do believe i didn't
read the letter because that's like such
an invasion of privacy but i do believe
inside the letter is a long list of book
recommendations if you wanted to just
read aloud and sue's rex
i will i'll share them at a later date
but i want to read the letter first
maybe there's some context in there so
yeah thank you so much and sue you know
i'm an anti-file and i'm just so glad
that this made its way to me where's msu
from i believe detroit but i can't
remember it's all a blur
that's so exciting definitely detroit
yeah thank you for bringing that in for
me and i have a present for you which is
that i'm wearing some end log merch yes
so cute this is my favorite piece from
the collection me too just her
nice spotch
um right there on my belly what size are
you wearing i'm wearing an xl because
that's what you gave me xl i didn't give
it to you like i didn't size you at an
xl it was just the one laying around and
that's what i wanted but i mean it is
it is really long on me i wouldn't say
xl is my size no you know these days
i'll just wear anything that fits over
my body it fits the chips yeah so i
would have probably gotten i mean
depends how you're wearing it right but
i think it is a dress today i think it's
really true to size so don't oh it is
totally true to size i wear it in excel
which is what i wear all the merch in
it's at shopmorningchokes.com if you
click on the menu there's a little thing
that says not like other girls which has
the koozies beanies t-shirts kernex i
wore the quebec earlier in the week
jackie's wearing the t-shirt thank you
for the end log tour merch support no
problem it's so cute i was so excited to
wear it thanks um we have a great show
for you guys because it's wednesday and
that means nothing but it means our
spirits are high did you watch
vanderpump rules yes i forgot wow what a
boring [ __ ] episode yeah i did watch
we'll recap there were so many fast
forward worthy scenes though no there
were so many moments where i felt
personally offended that this is what
they chose to show me to subject us to
yeah it was really bad okay so yes i
forgot we'll definitely talk about that
we'll cover the fast five
and
anything else you want to recap i
finished my book the rose code it was
amazing and i
everyone was recommending it up down
left and right for a reason and i don't
know why i didn't read it sooner it
would it's like always on every list
it's so weird how i just like will skip
some books sometimes just i guess we're
just judging books based on their covers
so which is so hard not to i know i
loved it so much five stars people are
asking me how it compares to the alice
network which is by the same author i've
not read the alice network either i
guess i've just been like boycotting
this author so i'm going to read the
alice network but i do need a break i've
read like a few serious books in a row
and i need just something like light and
i need an amuse bouche and then i'll get
back on my grind but i can only read so
many you know war books in a row it's so
important to amuse your bush constantly
yeah so i'm i've been looking for an
amuse boosher
and i don't know what it's gonna be
speaking of bushes
i
posted a clip yesterday on our instagram
um of just a funny moment of us talking
about periods coming out of your throat
in space and we went a little viral on
tic tac i posted the clip on tick tock
we got 200 000 views and you know for me
like my sad tick tock account follow me
at girl no job um that was big for me
yeah oh my god that's so exciting you
should post more clips i i try to i
don't want to like be annoying um i
don't i want to only post like the
premium stuff is it annoying too because
either goes viral because people are
enjoying it or goes nowhere because it
was annoying people yeah i just like i
don't know i'm very selective about my
talks
are you yeah i i haven't seen your page
in a while i don't know how often you're
talking because you you don't really
share everything that you talk on
instagram instagram but i just did want
to read if i may my last couple videos
um views
me and you 160 000. that was yes space
and yes i made one about the movie
something borrowed 222 000. i made a
taylor's version all too well video in
my dressing room a hundred thousand i
did a dance in my dressing room 120 000.
i made one with counselor thanksgiving
175 000. i don't know i'm like kind of
a tick tocker well if i could if i could
spot a pattern here if i may
it sounds like all those ones that are
doing well for you or just like your
ideas of things that you were doing not
necessarily like trends no it's the
exact opposite they're all trends really
the um
let me see them again like every single
one that i just mentioned is a trend
really go back explain how what the
trend is sure okay so not the tick tock
one the one that i posted yesterday of
course of course okay so the one about
something borrowed it's a trend you sing
to the song i could watch you for a
lifetime oh my god okay you're my
favorite movie
the all too well version like people
were doing you were tossing me the car
keys like i copied the trend okay um
what dancing in my dressing room was a
trend dance to an olymer song
oh oh okay and i love that song but some
of these i saw
you there
sitting all alone in the dark acting
like you didn't have the care
i knew right there that you'd be mine
and we'd be dancing the whole damn night
so good
so good ollie mers is so [ __ ]
underrated and that song has been out
forever and it's so funny what just like
i know it gets picked up and i'm so
happy that this song is getting justice
and then that what a mean stitch was
like a thanksgiving trend like i i'm i'm
following the trends like i'm a
trendsetter well okay so it sounds like
you're just your talk is like the same
of what you've been doing it's just been
doing really well yeah and i'm just
really proud of myself i'm so proud
happy for you follow me on tick-tock
with no job
cool cool
um
so yes vanderpump rules we will recap
and i really did a whole bunch of
nothing yesterday
yeah i had a very chill day with bruisal
we read all day i had to like plow
through the book because it was so good
and i was just like getting answers
answers answers and it was actually a
really enjoyable day of reading that's
nice yeah it was really nice and our
episode was so funny i was just like
giggling all day about like the [ __ ] we
said on the toast yesterday such a good
time just a little unhinged it's always
good to add a dash of unhinged to your
tuesday episode you never know when it's
gonna come and the girl with the tip jar
that's what really was making me giggle
all day yeah that was crazy i hope that
someone sends her that episode me too
your toasters is wild
um
you want to jump right in yeah yeah i'm
ready without further ado it is time for
the fast life stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of the morning toast
without further ado it is time for you
to wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
um okay today's episode is brought to
you by jackie's absolute favorite brand
babel
learning a new language can feel
intimidating when we first decided
to jump into babel it's like a huge
undertaking and you feel like very
nervous because it's like you're back in
school um you can be worried about the
level of difficulty the time commitment
and having to hear how your accent
sounds out loud but thanks to babel the
number one selling language learning app
the whole process was addictively fun
fast and easy whether you want to learn
a new language for an upcoming trip or
as an engaging new hobby babble teaches
bite-sized language lessons for
real-world use so they have 15-minute
lessons on babel that make it easy and
the perfect way to learn a new language
on the go other language learning apps
use ai for their lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over a hundred
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german so obviously
if you're planning a trip like i did a
couple battles before i went to rome um
if you don't speak spanish that's
definitely something you should think
about doing and babble's a great way to
learn
there's just like a million different
reasons why you might want to pick up a
language um
a hobby
feel challenged expand your mind of
course if you're taking a trip you meet
someone who's italian you fall in love
you need to learn italian start your new
language learning journey today with
babel right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
so that's six months for the price of
just three just go to babel.com and use
the promo code tmt as in the morning
toast tmt is the code that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com code tmt
babble language for life
great our first story 2021's top style
star according to google searches is
here and you will never guess i could
give you one million guesses wait what
and you would never guess who suck him
it's not kim okay wait what's the title
again
according to google's year in search
report for 2021 this person is the
person whose get-ups people could not
stop googling
oh man or woman man
kanye no no like i need to think outside
my yeah you're not gonna guess it and
it's quite what is quite shocking it's
adam sandler
what with you know his all of his like
yeah of course like jim shorts [ __ ]
outfits yeah well he came out on top in
the celebrity outfits category this year
ahead of some of the more expected names
how many people searched for his outfits
i'm not sure but i mean must have been
millions
wait that is
wait i'm like so underwhelmed by the
answer i know they're gonna say like
virgil like of course that's why i said
you will never guess it's funny that we
spend more time looking up unless adam
sandler maybe he really is the inspo for
2021 fashion that would explain a lot it
would but people are like so head over
heels obsessed with adam sandler like
his core fan base like would literally
take a bullet for him like they're
insane so this doesn't like surprise me
and it's like funny but it's
like i can imagine him making the list
of top 10 like as a joke but not being
number one like yeah yeah no but he is
number number one i think that really
sums up the year you guys 100 at first i
was like oh are we spending more time
like you know looking at things like to
make fun of versus looking at inspo but
perhaps
perspective shift this is the inspo yeah
no he's like a chaotic mess with a
ketchup on his shirt and i definitely
feel as though i've been inspired by him
in some sort of way fashion wise
yeah honestly it's kind of iconic now
that i'm really looking at him like some
of his loops look at these uggs i i
never really thought about his fashion i
just think about that meme that like
billy eilish dresses like adam sandler
totally not really anymore but yeah yeah
when she was in her heyday yeah oh that
is so funny
um well i'm happy for adam sandler i
feel like he actually lives such a
fabulous life like he's
so rich he makes
maybe a movie a year now he just like
hangs out with his family and is still
like so famous and iconic when i was at
nyu he lives around there and he like
goes to the nyu gym i don't know how he
gets in you need a student id to get in
and he waits for people on the
basketball court who like want to play
basketball and like plays with the kids
that's why he's always in basketball
shorts yes ready for a game at any time
always going to cole's gym like always
that is really
sweet it was sweet but like i always
wondered like how did you get in the gym
it's like high security he's a professor
maybe he's got like some sort of
honorary degree yeah or maybe he's like
a teacher's assistant yeah but it was
very exciting for the kids
happy for the kids yeah i think i went
to the gym like once just to see if he
was there and then he wasn't and i never
went back damn
well are you ready for our next story
sure some surprising news drake
hemsley's husband p.k clemsley was
arrested for a dui
what listen to the story pk was arrested
for a dui in november after having a
glass of wine at dinner and driving on
the 101 in los angeles the husband of
real housewives of beverly hills star
derek hemsley was pulled over just off
loyal canyon on november 23rd and blew a
.081 during a breathalyzer test point
zero eight one the legal is point zero
eight yes and then he was arrested and
brought to the police station in van nuy
where he took another breathalyzer test
and blew a
.073 so he was just like right on the
cusp i guess that equates to a glass of
wine otherwise i would say how would you
know what he drank
really is .08 one glass one
well it depends on the person it depends
on the timing of the drink it depends
like how much they weigh how tall they
are we all took these classes in
high school that really no i have no
idea what you're talking about or maybe
it's in college where they explain how
like alcohol affects your blood alcohol
levels i must have been drunk
um okay let me tell you
this i think this a lot when i watch
housewives because they all like drive
to each other's homes and [ __ ] and i'm
like why are none of you taking uber's
like i'm so crazy like if i
if someone like has a sip of beer i'm
like oh guess i'm ubering like i'm very
dramatic that way well it's easy for you
to say in new york city yes of course
but like
i'm i'm sorry there's just no excuse
like even if you're having one glass of
wine people like say like you can have a
beer and drink like i'm so nuts like no
you can't actually like i would never
get in a car with someone who had a beer
but you can because i would have the lim
like the limit is point zero eight for a
reason no i get it but i still wouldn't
got it well uh he were like people who
smoke pot and drive i would never do
that no and and and that's
it's like not illegal right because how
do you test for that on the spot i don't
know i don't know either anyways then pk
was taken home where he was met by more
police officers who are there guarding
his home oh god yeah and um
that's that's the story it reminds me
of the book that you made me read when
life gives you lululemons she gets
pulled over for a dui and it's like this
whole conspiracy not that i think it's a
conspiracy but it's like very unclear on
like whether he was drunk or not yeah no
like he was right on the line i don't
know how that moves forward and it's
also like when they did take him in for
additional testing he was below
yeah but also like isn't it like the
longer you wait then like your blood
alcohol will go down right so if only he
had stayed at the restaurant for a
minute but apparently he really was that
well they said he was at dinner with a
colleague and he had one glass of wine
which like should be okay to drive yeah
but oh my god that sucks do you think
it's gonna be a storyline
i don't know i when i first read the
headline like i was like oh my god i
thought it happened last night oh my
gosh um but
i don't know if it'll be a story line
because when bella hadid at 14 got a dui
that was a storyline because that was
[ __ ] crazy yeah but also to be like
point one above the limit is really
different than some of the other dui of
course i'm sorry
like ran a red light she was like
running around with like alcohol in her
car
he was point zero zero one over the
limit right so that's
a different story yeah i don't know if
it'll come up plus three has so much
going on i don't know if the ladies are
gonna bring it up i like
really i'm trying hard like i judge
people so hard like i never ever
honestly will support sam hunt ever
again like after what he did like i
just feel like drunk driving is
just so stupid like take an uber it's so
easy take a cab like back in the day
wouldn't have uber i could understand
maybe you just gotta get home but now
it's like there's literally no excuse so
i do judge but like honestly i think
pretty much every celebrity on the
planet has a dui so like if that were
the case i'd be boycotting all of
hollywood but you know what i'm about to
start doing i'm sick of them and they're
and they're nonsense okay
um
that's your prerogative yeah i think the
sam hunt thing bothered me so much
because he like put up an apology and
like deleted it and like never really
took uh responsibility for his actions
when he drove the wrong way on a road
yeah
it's so embarrassing yeah is he still
married yep
he's so like weird and located he is so
low-key and like
he was the biggest like country star of
like the year and then like disappeared
yeah and it was kind of on his own terms
yeah and then he like started to come
back and got the dui yeah but he then he
put out an album last year that was
flames yeah but he didn't like
promoting yeah he's extremely low key
maybe he's really just in it for the
music well that i would refer to the
love of music that i would respect
yeah no it's a weird trajectory yeah for
sure
are ready for our next story yes rebel
wilson got pushback from her team when
she started losing weight she says
rebel wilson says she didn't have the
full support of those around her when
she began her health journey during a
recent interview with bbc news the
actress opened up about some of the
negative responses she received when
beginning her year of health mainly due
to her career as the funny fat girl on
screen right she said i got a lot of
pushback from my own team actually here
in hollywood when i said okay i'm going
to do this year of health i feel like
i'm really going to physically transform
and change my life and they were like
why why would you want to do that
because i was earning millions of
dollars being a funny fat girl and being
that person
last year the pitch perfect actress lost
nearly 80 pounds she said that she was a
confident woman and loved herself before
losing the weight but she knew deep down
inside that her emotional eating habits
weren't healthy
i don't know i really like have a lot of
thoughts like i don't want to be
controversial so i think i'll just shut
up
what are your thoughts are they
i'm they're very conflicting like i'm
fully like i'm just gonna say how i feel
and just know like you can poke holes in
my theory like i'm not saying this is
foolproof like it's just how i feel okay
i just like can't help but roll my eyes
like okay
let me tell you why like
i i understand what you're i just roll
my eyes and just like oh you're skinny
now it's so hard for you like shut up
first of all and second of all yes and i
talked about this like with adele it is
nobody's business to comment on whether
or not you think she should have lost
the weight it's her [ __ ] business
it's her body i'm never gonna comment on
whether i wish she had stayed that i
wish she had lost my rate i would never
do that
but
there's just so
little like fat people in hollywood and
then when they get really famous like
they get skinny and betray us and like
it's like rude like stay with us take
that with us oh that's so interesting my
pov was gonna be a little different
which is like i feel like she has such
like
small-minded and uncreative people
around her if like they really think
that she's funny because she's fat and
actually i feel like in some of the
stuff that they would put her in it was
really just like throwing her at
something and saying go be fat i come
and they really agree there wasn't any
like other creativity comedic elements
and i actually think that like
these people are really the people who
are around her she needs a new team that
can like think outside the box because
like rebel wilson is a comedian 100
people who happened to have been fat but
they were only leaning into that okay
that is such a good point but also yes i
definitely blame her team but i think
like it's also just a byproduct of the
industry like you have a come-ups like
melissa mccarthy it's a very similar you
just fall into this trope but it's like
the only roles you get you're not
getting like you know the leading uh the
leading role in a romantic comedy you're
always the bad funny friend so it's like
yes the team around you is moronic but i
think it's also just the industry like
when you come up like that's who you are
do you think that it's changing like at
all
no
you don't think that there are shows or
movies where
the lead
is that no
what about like shrill
okay fine there's one show trail and it
was atrocious and i'm also just like
trying to think about no i know yes i do
think like things are changing
a little bit but maybe not at the speed
that like but yes okay shrill but like
shrill like honestly
me like
i'm not gonna say what i really thought
about troll okay because i like her
first season i thought it was fine but
like her apartment was gross and you
know there is this like stigma that like
fat people are disgusting you know like
fat people can't take care of themselves
they don't have jobs and i also felt
like shrill was kind of contributing to
that like her apartment was disgusting
she'd never cleaned up after herself
that's like a bad stereotype about
people who are fat so it's like she's
just
continuing those stereotypes and
honestly i found it offensive like my
apartment is very clean i'm a very very
clean person i took a shower yesterday i
have a full-fledged career she was like
the worst at her job like she was just
falling into every fat stereotype i
don't really feel like shrill did
anything for the fat movement sorry okay
okay
let me see like a really clean organized
powerful
successful yeah please drop that diva
the best show on television but you know
what the best part was she was skinny on
the inside that's why she had all this
confidence because in her former life
she was thin
but yes thank you we need to bring back
drop that diva literally justice for
jane i [ __ ] loved that show i really
didn't like it i know it changed my life
like actually i can't believe you didn't
like it i loved it maybe i just didn't
get far enough in yeah no it was so good
ben loved it too i just really i really
didn't like it so yes like i'm so happy
for rebel wilson again i will never
comment like if someone wants to lose
weight they want to get fat live your
life like that is so on you i'm never
gonna like comment on it
but like this whole like you know
how sad like i'm skinny now and like
people like didn't agree with it like
sorry
yeah also get new team members around
you if they really can't think outside
the yeah outside the box
i agree because you know what like at
her peak career why it's like after
pitch perfect she was just being put in
these moronic roles like just being like
thrown across the room to do something
like silly and stupid like even though
it's a really good movie like how to be
single
okay that is a good movie and she was
great in it but um but she was like i'm
thinking of like the anne hathaway
movie
the heist or whatever like that was such
a stupid movie and like she was just
like they're stupid stupid yeah i agree
so
yeah it's it's a
byproduct of having non-creative people
around you
and the industry yeah mostly the
industry but yes great i'm glad we got
to the bottom of that me too and i'm
glad i was able to express my feelings
and i know like you know there's lots of
people who are like very you know
into like diet culture like i'm just
like please let me out of it like those
are my opinions and if you don't like it
like you just skip right to the next
part of the episode where we talk about
today's next story which is brought to
you
by pierbock
jackie aren't you tired of putting on a
ton of makeup in the morning it takes so
much time and it's not comfortable on
your skin yes i am so tired of it well
you've got to check out purevoc a
revolutionary hybrid of skincare and
makeup that creates a natural dewy look
to your skin and helps blur
imperfections that's why they named it
cover-up backwards pierbock it's
literally the reverse of covering up
it's one of the hottest beauty launches
of 2021 it's already been covered by a
ton of press um it's different than any
other skincare product i've used and of
course i've used many skincare products
in my life because you notice a
difference after the first application
it lasts all day it's and uh so
i think i've started like two weeks two
months ago using it um you're definitely
seeing a difference in the everyday look
and feel of your skin and the best part
is that you're able to leave your house
without any makeup and still feel
confident in the skin that you're in um
so that's like the problem when you're
having problematic skin and then you
have to pile on makeup to go to work it
makes it so much worse so purevoc is
like kind of a genius concept it's
makeup and skincare and one you're
healing your skin you're taking care of
your skin you're letting your skin
breathe but you're also covering up
imperfections adding a little life to
your skin and it's just like a genius
genius product um you can reverse the
cover up too with pierbock right now if
you go to wonderskin.com
and use the promo code toast you'll
you'll receive 20 off purebok or any of
the amazing products on the wonderskin
site plus free shipping with purchases
of over fifty dollars so that's twenty
percent off at w-o-n-d-e-r-s-k-i-n
dot com and use the promo code toast for
20 off at wonderskin.com
great our next story drake withdraws his
2022 grammy nominations drake has
withdrawn his two 2022 grammy
nominations the rep for the recording
atomy has recording academy has
confirmed to variety reps for drake did
not immediately respond to requests for
comment sources tell variety that the
decision was made by drake and his
management and the grammys honored the
request although his motivation was
unclear at the time of this article's
publication though there's speculation
that it is because he is named in the
astro world lawsuits that he like took
himself out of the running oh wait what
yeah that's what the article says oh my
perception before i had heard that was
like
i think a lot of artists are like really
fed up with like being so beholden to
the grammys and in a way if drake like
takes himself out of it and like other
big artists do that they're like taking
away the legitimacy of the grammys
because a lot of them have been super
outspoken about how it's completely
rigged right um
but the astral world thing makes a lot
of sense too but it doesn't it doesn't
because it's like
i just don't think he would be receiving
accolades you know while
people are grieving
yeah but i don't think that he would
then if if it really is
wrong place wrong time then he just
wouldn't win but wouldn't go yeah but
why have to like go through this process
of like taking your name out of the
nominations honestly your theory
sounds i think so too and i think you
know the weekend has been really open
about
the kanye too like about how it's just
like so stupid but it like it's so well
respected in the industry that it's like
annoying because it's so rigged but it's
also like the thing you want the most so
if people at the top of their game like
kind of step aside it's like oh well
drake doesn't care about the grammys
like i won't either yeah but it's
confusing because one it's like the
nominations came out a while ago so if
you're upset to be nominated like when
you have taken yourself out then two
don't you nominate yourself to be
nominated like don't your management
yeah you put forth what you want to like
be in the running represent so that's a
little unclear
and it's um also rather than giving the
nomination to the next person in line
who had like the sixth most votes
um they're just doing four
categories yeah for like the whoever was
six in line yeah it's a really weird
like a random move i hope we get a
little more clarity
if it's one of these reasons or maybe a
completely different one yeah i'm
unclear to be honest
did you see that um
the girl who tristan got pregnant and
has like been putting up all these
instagram stories and she had put up a
story that drake and kylie had sex last
year
i i think i saw that i saw a lot of
stuff yeah but see i don't know which of
her accounts is real but and then i also
saw a cash app link in her bio yeah so
that always makes me think like it's a
fake person pretending to be this person
you think but then she was also talking
about like doja cat's birthday party and
had messages from tristan saying don't
bring doja into this yeah yeah i forgot
about that i and her page um
didn't have you know the
the um stock photo of the newborn right
it had a sonogram picture
and i i was looking at it like this is
the real girl with the cash app link in
her bio yeah i mean if it wasn't the
real girl it's a very creative like
she's like using a lot of details using
a lot of color yeah and also if jake and
kylie did have sex how cute
how cute
how cute not cute if drake also had sex
with kim
also
then people are like
well if it was last year and she's
pregnant oh god get out of here
yeah i agree i don't think he's the
father no i don't think so either but
like i totally ship like drake joining
the kardashians that would be so
fabulous yeah i ship completely but um
and i do for some reason i don't know
why i just thought that was her page
yeah no because it's being shared a lot
like it's just being kind of accepted as
valid as gospel and i'm not here for it
yeah i'm not here for what she's putting
out are you ready for the fifth and
final story
no but you're gonna get ready
thank you jackie i couldn't have said it
better myself
it's the final story
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah you know what i was actually
realizing yesterday i don't think the
key we're singing final countdown in is
really my best key well you lead it off
so if we're not in your key then i know
my fault i'm really not talented enough
to like know how to change a kid
okay so you're singing right now
it's the final story
no that's not what i was doing sorry
what i was doing was
you know i'll have to work out this
arrangement out with like my producer
like i'll figure it out okay look at the
mirror and figure it out
our fifth and final story is a little
sex in the city reboot news and just
like that i can't believe the name
the name kills me i'm actually looking
forward to watching this like i am going
to watch did you watch a trailer yeah i
thought it was cute like i'm i'm excited
like to see what they do
but i why is that called sex in the city
okay and if they're thinking about going
for something else why aren't they going
for like i couldn't help but wonder like
and just like that like i can't even say
it without cringing and all i could
think is and just like that oh
and i love that song and i hate this no
but also i don't really
hear and just like that and think of
carrie bradshaw that's really not one of
her signature lines her signature line
is i couldn't help but wonder
yeah no but why can't it just be
sex in the city right it's on hbo like
they own the rights but i think they do
like this isn't season
yeah like it's so okay they wanted to be
a separate show but like
there are so many ways that they could
have done that without this annoying
title like after the sex or something
yeah that's good
yeah
i thought the trailer was not it but i'm
glad that you thought it was good
anyways here's the headline okay
and just like that film
i can't get past it sexist city reboot
filmed fake scenes to throw off fan
spoilers that's kind of cool
kristen davis and cynthia nixon have
revealed that they filmed fake scenes of
the highly anticipated sex and the city
spin-off and just like that in order to
confuse lovers of the iconic tv show the
actresses made the admission during a
sit-down interview just two days before
the premiere which is on thursday
filming of the series has taken place in
new york city over the past five months
with fans trying to deduce spoilers from
paparazzi photos taken during production
but they now reveal that some scenes
won't actually make the final cut um
because they were intended to dupe which
is like yeah it's such a waste of time
and resources but
i guess hbmx is just [ __ ] money now
to like make fake scenes um but it's
true like
i've seen so much stuff on like dumour
and all these accounts like you really i
guess
back in the day like when gossip girl
and sex and city used to film in new
york like social media wasn't really as
like
prevalent and wasn't so fast like you
could get away with like shooting
something on the corner and like a
couple people seeing and not becoming
headline news so i guess this is like a
creative way of doing it like okay film
on sound stage like
what yeah but no but they need all these
like new york locations yeah yeah no
it's definitely an excessive use of time
imagine like being one of the actors and
having to film the scene that you know
is just trashed
in the tin
um
so i was actually talking about it with
my friends last night we went to dinner
and i think that miranda
is probably going to be a lesbian
because like
in the trailer it like looked like she
was like
i just felt i got that vibe from it and
my friends were also saying that they
got that vibe too and cynthia nixon like
is so proud and out in real life i feel
like she would want to bring that to her
character that's just one of my calls
like i think that oh interesting yeah
like i think her and steve are
co-parenting while she explores her
sexuality interesting and in the trailer
big is there right yeah and they're
together i don't yeah
and aiden is
was he in it was he i didn't see him i
don't know but like they said that he
was gonna be in it i just i can't stand
carrie and her like i'm really tuning in
for i love eat sleep and breathe and
like love miranda and charlotte and
obviously samantha like who makes the
show and the show will ultimately be a
failure without her um
so i'm so uninterested in what's going
on at harry so i think i will be
fast-forwarding through her scenes yeah
so for me i did not find the trailer to
like be something that i felt like i
needed to watch so i i'm not gonna say
i'm not gonna watch it but if everyone
says oh my god this is amazing you have
to watch then i will and if i if it's
like you know
mom's the word then yeah i'm not
watching it's just for me i think the
fatal flaw of the show was always carrie
and was always like her dumb
decisions and but but at the same time i
was like oh she was like a young girl in
new york i don't think she could pull
this [ __ ] at 60 carrie so i think she
better have gotten her [ __ ] together
and stopped making
moronic decisions because i just don't
think that's gonna cut it for the
viewers as a six-year-old woman
frolicking around new york in a stupid
hat like throwing your life away yeah
you'll let me know i will i'm actually
looking forward to it okay well it
straps tomorrow sex in the city is one
of like my comfort shows like friends
like i feel that so i'm it's exciting
excitement excites you you know what i
did watch last night well most of no i
watch it i finish it i think jonas
brothers family rose oh what did you
think and i didn't despise it as much as
you did we're officially moving into the
tv recap segment those were the five
stories oh yeah no but it was just like
i don't know that i'm gonna recap
because you already did but i just
wanted to say i did not despise it as
much as you did like there were some
really funny moments some interesting
dynamics at play would have loved to see
the camera on priyanka's face when they
made that meghan markle joke but she was
nowhere to be found even though priyanka
like was literally peeing in her pants
i've never seen anyone laugh harder more
totally throughout the entire time at
herself too like at literally everything
like she must be such a fun person to be
around because she just laughs at
everything yeah same with kevin jonas
yeah no one can take a joke like kevin
and also like kevin it's like he really
got the brunt of all the jokes and they
were a little too repetitive like
everyone had a trope like yeah kevin was
like who and nick was like broke up the
band joe solo career
yeah and so and then also like everyone
making fun of jonas brothers music was
like yeah and so i would have liked a
little more you know creativity under
the surface jokes but
i there were some laughs there i thought
pete davidson was hysterical he was when
he came out as frankie jonas i was
crying crying that was hysterical that
you know he lives off of his christmas
and birthday presents he was the best
part of it no doubt i thought that
actually the more i ruminated on the
roast the more terrible i thought it was
like i thought it was such a waste of
time and energy and money it was just
like a little random i skipped all the
packages because you said like such bad
things okay she only watches like 30
minutes i only watched the roast
things yeah did danielle jonas really
lose her voice no i think that like she
is not a celebrity like she's a mom and
she's a former hairdresser she's a
jewelry designer she can't speak in
front of hundreds of people most normal
people can't yeah so i think that like
she wanted to be involved but like was
not
and also most normal people like would
not want to get up in in front of a
televised room of a couple hundred
people let alone do stand-up that's like
the hardest thing you can do so i just
think like she wanted to be involved for
sure but like not in that way okay that
was fine and there were some really
funny jokes in hers like you know most
like the rest of our world our daughters
didn't know you were famous
funny um
and it was just interesting to see all
the like relationship dynamics at play
like especially between like nick and
priyanka i didn't realize that they're
age different like maybe when they
started dating we talked about it but
now i'm like i know she's older than him
but like i didn't realize 10 years yeah
me neither actually something i never
even thought about yeah and then like
sophie and joe but they're all i don't
know it was just like it was a little it
was a little crazy
i really i like i hated it i hated it
hated it and i loved the jonas brothers
i didn't hate it i i i was like i found
myself smiling at times i had a few
laughs out loud and also i don't i
didn't know who jack whitehall was me
neither but he was hysterical yeah he
was really good i guess he's a big
comedian in the uk and he and i googled
oh wow that is interesting yeah i ship
but now they're broken up um before we
talk about vanderpump rules i did also
last night to start the sex lives of
college girls which is like a new mindy
kaling show on hbo max that people are
loving and i think i'm like two or three
episodes in it's like cute i definitely
feel like a little old to be watching it
i can't explain it um but it's kind of
small that you are yeah no but it's a
cute and like i really don't think i'm
emotionally ready to like start aging
out of things so i'm forcing myself to
like it okay okay it's really good
whatever you need to do
um but let's talk about pump rules which
was on last night which is brought to
you by curology
curology customizes a prescription
formula with three active ingredients
picked for you to help tackle your
skincare needs whether that may be
trying to take control of acne or fine
lines dark spots occasional breakouts
you start by answering questions online
with curology about your skin and if
it's a good fit curology will match you
with a licensed dermatology provider who
will get to know your skin and subject
to consultation you'll get a customized
prescription cream to be shipped
straight to your door
to address the fine lines acne dark
spots and more so the curology um
philosophy is actually really pretty
genius when you think about it like we
all have such different skin we have
different problems combination oil dry
and we really shouldn't all be using the
same products and curology is
custom making your skin care routine for
you the online consultation is actually
very in-depth you send tons of pictures
of your face all these different
questions about your skin type what um
problems you're trying to address and
curology really really custom makes an
entire routine for you that is different
than anyone else's because your skin is
different than anyone else's not like
other girls you can start your curology
journey just like we did with a free
30-day trial at curology.com toast if
prescribed just pay five dollars for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com toast to unlock your free 30-day
trial cancel anytime so if you've been
like really just like done with your
skin and ready to take control of it
check out curology it's
it works
great vanderpump rules
woof okay i mean i think let's start
with all the scenes i fast forwarded the
photo shoot with the feet
the screaming um
therapy with sandals
um i actually didn't fast forward the
ice baths because i was just like
curious about no and it was so early on
that like it just like they sucked me in
somehow and it looked miserable yeah no
but i'm i was you know impressed by all
of them they just got in and you did it
um
i want to talk about the feet thing
because i had so much respect for lala
for being like no absolutely absolutely
not but i also had respect for sheena
for like getting for like trying to
participate and you know she's so
much more mature than these girls this
is not like you know she all of her
friends are off the show like these
girls are
not her people but she really like tried
to get ingratiate herself with the new
generation she hired the photographer
she had them at her house like that's
true it she was really trying so i
thought that was really sweet so i i
respected the people who didn't do it
and i respected the people who did yeah
also um i guess the only person i don't
ever respect for is a person whose idea
it was charlie because it's a moronic
idea moronic i was so glad to see
throughout the episode that they no one
kicks did not sell i think that by the
end like one of arianas did right that
was obviously like not gonna cover the
bill thirty thousand dollars no um
one of the dumbest
premises of television air time i've
ever seen i agree what i did think was
interesting was this whole charlie
sheena and brock's friend thing because
i like really
kind of felt both of them like
yes that guy was really inappropriate
with charlie and that's like sheena's
boyfriend's friend like sheena should
have said something but also charlie's
boyfriend was right behind her and
sheena was like sheena did get caught in
a lie saying i didn't see it but then i
was like oh your boyfriend was behind
you so you did see it but also like her
boyfriend had it handled like it wasn't
getting out of control what the hell is
sheena gonna do she's like two months
postpartum who is she gonna fight off
you know yeah no charlie like handled it
i guess she just like wanted some backup
support for machina which she didn't get
and it's interesting to see like
the collapse of like the sheena
dictatorship among her minion friends
yeah the young girls ariana was on my
trap inside and she's like i've never
felt sheen as a dictator but that's not
the kind of friendship that we have but
that's because it's a different dynamic
because you're equals but sheena like
does recruit these girls and like
they're she's helping them like come
into the full but she requires like
unwavering loyalty in return like that
danica stuff was wild right and then
watching charlie and markell like put
together that like sheena's not really a
good friend to them it's like
hate to see it you know what i also love
like postpartum sheena doesn't give a
[ __ ] like i think before her kid like
every time someone would have a problem
with her she was like really invested in
it like every time someone would pull
her for a chat she would like give it
her whole that conversation with charlie
she was like i'm sorry
yeah because no she was
charlie like literally read her to filth
yeah but i also think she doesn't give a
[ __ ] like no she was just completely
called out and there was no route to
take other than i'm sorry just like last
week when katie and lala called her out
for like running to tom sandoval telling
uh him what they said about him and like
she just keeps backing herself into
these corners it's not that she doesn't
give a [ __ ] she has nowhere else to turn
yeah also when she was at the table and
everyone was ganging up on her and she
was like i just like i left my dog like
my kid for this like i just want to go
home to my baby it's like so now you
know how lalala has been feeling all
season literally
also um can we talk about this whole
photo shoot james broadcasting please
okay because yes i do think james being
annoying like you help out a friend but
i don't know i do think that brock is
like taking advantage of everyone here
like they agree they're all celebrities
they all have huge instagram followings
and yes they're all friends but like if
this was just a random fitness app who
wanted to like use them for a photo
shoot their name and likeness like they
might have been getting paid like maybe
like 50 to 100 grand for this like they
it's not nothing so no uh that's that's
a that's extreme say it was um just an
instagram post like at least oh just an
instagram post
yeah like he was on the one hand i think
brock asks them to like post stuff all
the time like texting
and that stuff that would at least
charge like 3k depending on the person
yeah yeah yeah
and also he wants that that was
interesting when james said like you're
always sending us stuff to post no and
that just gave me like a window into
brock that is like a major red flag
especially because like he has sheena
sheena's partner she know will support
him but to like use all of your
connections in that way when you haven't
even launched anything yet so like what
what's gonna happen when you do have
some [ __ ] that they need to promote yeah
no that was a very telling
thing and i do think like on the surface
yeah it sounds like james is being
annoying but you know it sounds like
[ __ ] brock's being annoying and
taking advantage of everyone in this
group whom that he just met and to
launch all these random businesses i
agree for everyone on the show when
they're not filming the show like
instagram is their job and you are
asking these people over not just once
it seems to be like over and over again
friends like friends at like if any of
my friends ever ask like i'm watching of
course like but if it's like non-stop
i'm like girl no and also it's different
to like hey can you come to my launch
party and support me yeah that's
different than can you come be a model
host the sling the face of this brand
and also post about it like that's
something that like for these people
they get their agents involved right
they get paid right so
i'm not surprised that someone said
something i'm surprised that it was
james me too i thought it maybe would
have been like lala like it could have
been anyone
or yeah anyway because you know when you
think about it like they're all huge on
social they all monetize their instagram
and this is [ __ ] like yeah and also
it's like i don't know what his
businesses say it's like a fitness app
like then then they then it's like a
non-compete with the next brand that
they can't work with in the future like
this is their
their career career and so
i didn't think james was being egomaniac
at all
i thought that you know
brock was asking for a lot of free
services right and apparently this is
not the first time yeah which was just
very interesting to learn but you know
what i was also thinking like brock is
as much as i like literally can't stand
him he's like becoming one of the main
characters of the season like he will
grow a huge instagram like he has made
himself known and if the show continues
like he will no doubt being
be asked back like i want to see how
many followers he has right now i don't
know if
101 okay not bad not bad so i just think
like he's definitely understanding the
opportunity he's been given to be on
this show and like the implications it
could have for him and his business and
whatever i think he's putting the car
before the horse i think when gina said
he has a kid to take care of and lala
was like actually he has three i lost my
mind like yeah did you forget
no i literally lost my mind that picnic
was like so stupid and so funny and like
everyone was like miss like they all
them all showing up just like in fairy
princess dresses like they're
like 35 years old like sitting in a park
in a poofy dress like
i could i just know katie maloney felt
stupid because like it was stupid yeah
and that's where it's like you know
raquel and katie being on the same show
raquel and lalala like lala has a child
like it's just that's where the show
doesn't make sense sometimes no it was
all so stupid katie's really doing her
best to be
so much respect for katie yeah no i was
thinking of her and like i actually
really like her friendship with ariana
because i actually do think they're both
way smarter than their partners and they
know it um
but this sand of all stuff is like so
out of control and thankfully he was
like not in this episode that much like
that's what made it somewhat tolerable
but of course he will come back no even
like like the previous he barely no no
he like wasn't majorly in it but he
still found ways to annoy me for example
when he showed up to pickleball and he
was like oh damn i should have worn
ariana's cheerleading uniform it's like
no if he thought of that before he left
the house like he would have shown up
yeah and ariana cheerleading before then
when like later in the thing i think
that maybe it was during the national
anthem yes oh i know what you're going
to say was like extra i love it yes yes
yes i noticed that too oh this is so
extra man i love it
and then like he's the only one who's
ever allowed to do something slightly
over the top
and then tom and ariana were and watch
what happens live
and ariana was like so great she gets
cuter and cuter every episode tom
just like when he's asked a question
just like it's a bunch of words strung
together he doesn't ever finish his
sentence and he doesn't say anything he
should work in marketing it's just like
a word salad
that's what it's called i don't know how
she deals no he shouldn't work in
marketing he's not convincing me of
anything no i know but like like he's
working corporate like buzzwords it
wasn't even buzzwords honestly it was a
lot of like
it was a lot of like you know um like
just
what are you trying to say
yeah oh my god he's so infuriating and
honestly the previews for next week
where he like basically tells tom
schwartz that they need to take a break
because tom schwartz for the first time
in his life in the most sad way ever
like tries to defend his wife like i
cannot stand tom sandoval and i'm like
annoyed that all this stuff is happening
off air with like james and raquel and
lala and randall because the reunion is
obviously going to be focused on that
when i need like a full sit down like we
need an intervention with tom sandoval
we do
and i have to be honest i think jax
leaving the show was
the worst thing that ever happened to
tom sandoval because it really put a
spot like cause he was always going
toe-to-toe with they were always like
you know getting under each other
getting on each other's nerves and jax
is like the villain so jax was always in
the wrong but it really him leaving has
shown a spotlight on how
insufferable tom sandoval is oh my god
but when charlie was like well you're
friends with jax who said horrible
things about me oh my god like way to
pull this reference out of your ass i
loved it like no no charlie like came
with answers
that's why sheena had nothing to say
other than i'm sorry you're right yeah
actually i had a lot of respect for
charlie this episode yeah she go she
like goes up and down between being like
super strong in like her
the way that she talks to people like
when she came for lala out of nowhere
and also just being like a a
quiet friend yeah i think she like just
climbs these random hills and like wants
wants to die on them and
sometimes i'm like what are you talking
about like how her whole storyline was
about like a dinner i was like okay why
are we here but then she like went super
hard on sheena i just think she chooses
the wrong things to like
make herself about you know yes i think
sometimes she chooses the wrong yeah
when she chooses the right things and
she puts the right energy forth she
she's makes a concise clear argument
yeah yeah um so it was like a dumb
episode full of lots of filler but it
was fine because mostly because tom
sandoval was like completely gone yeah
and i i considering i love ralla and i
love pickleball i did not mind the
pickleball tournament yeah and when that
guy sang i was like dying that was so
funny and he was really good he was
really good and that just seems like a
fun way to spend the afternoon totally
but maybe i'm biased um so tonight
what's on tonight
oc oh yeah okay oc's on tonight we will
recap that tomorrow
and that's our show that is our show
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the five stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so spotify itunes stitcher public radio
i have radio cast box all the places
where we listen to the podcast find out
it's morning totally a five-star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are if you made it to the end of this
episode congratulations you are a true
toaster who has respect for us and if
you want to let us know that you made it
to the end of the episode why don't you
go drop an emoji on our most recent
instagram of the basketball in honor of
adam sandler and his gorgeous shorts
love you bye